regularmente con otras víctimas de la
masacre del 28 de septiembre en este
centro Hace 13 años Fue violada por un
grupo de soldados al margen de la
manifestación reprimida con sangre hoy
acoge la apertura de un juicio con gran
alivio
He decidido no llorar pero es algo que
me carcome que ha destruido todo en mí
Pero afortunadamente hoy estoy aquí
todavía estoy testificando
en vísperas del juicio los equipos de
Aviva la principal asociación de
víctimas están más movilizados que nunca
desde el anuncio del juicio decenas de
personas se han presentado para declarar
Esta es la secretaría Ahí es donde
registramos a las víctimas y preparamos
sus expedientes la asociación mantiene
Grandes esperanzas
realmente queremos la verdad
queremos reparaciones queremos un
reconocimiento nacional para todas las
víctimas de los sucesos del 28 de
septiembre
y esperamos tener una justicia Clara y
transparente y no una parodia de la
justicia y en presencia de todos los que
han sido acusados en este caso
[Música]
11 personas han sido acusadas entre
ellas musadas cámara jefe de la junta en
el poder en el momento de la matanza y
quien comparecerá ante los jueces
Ahora tiene prisa por comparecer ante
los magistrados encargados de este caso
para entregar su parte de la verdad y
limpiar su honor e integridad que han
sido manchados durante 13 años por estas
falsas acusaciones que no se basan en
ninguna prueba para seda que ya son
falacios quienes ser apóstol
candelemáprobanés cámara fue encarcelado
este martes junto a otros cinco Jesús
permanecerían en prisión Hasta el fin
del juicio según los abogados